mon fils il a dix ans j'ai commencé
cette conversation
si un collabo le message qu'on leur
lance soit plus président que les autres
n'est pas faire des mouvements brusques
n'est pas répondre au questionnaire les
policiers la conversation était très
nécessaire dès le début comme ça chez
depuis ma tendre bas-fonds 1 à ce qu'on
m'interpelle
cette conversation les familles blanches
ne la connaissent pas pourtant c'est une
préoccupation bien réel pour plusieurs
parents d'enfants noirs
comment les préparer à interagir avec un
policier j'essaie de leur expliquer
certains endroits dans le monde tout
dépendant de la couleur de ta peau une
vérification de routine ça peut mal viré
parce que le profilage racial existe la
famille et fériés souvent confrontés à
la prusse et là pour nous protéger mais
c'est une fausse de révolution
l'essentiel c'est d'essayer d'avoir un
comportement exemplaire pour éviter de
collaborer ça va pour la première fois
la deuxième fois mais j'ai pas vraiment
eu de conseils sur comment gérer cette
frustration pour la dix septième fois la
18e fois que le hasard fait en sorte
qu'on me contrôler le phénomène de cette
conversation a même fait l'objet d'un
documentaire aux états unis malgré la
différence de la réalité américaine la
crainte d'une interpellation musclée
inquiète
ici aussi c'est une crainte qui qui qui
qui existent en amérique du nord en
europe donc ce n'est pas réservé aux
états unis et c'est je trouve que c'est
dommage qu'on attend à que ça arrive ici
pour l'aborder en octobre dernier un
rapport de chercheurs mandatés par la
ville de montréal a révélé que les
personnes autochtones et noir avaient
entre quatre à cinq fois plus de chances
de se faire interpeller par des
policiers du spvm que les personnes
blanches
nous recevons des plaintes
2 profilage racial violon tiers a beau
occuper un poste à la commission des
droits de la personne
elle est aussi la mère d'un jeune homme
noir comme parent bien entendu on
s'attend que les services de police
protège nos enfants que de les protéger
on ne devrait pas avoir cette inquiétude
pour maryland lopez
il est grand temps justement d'élargir
cette conversation
tous les parents ont le devoir de parler
sur les racismes ici jacques andré
charbonneau raid au canada mon frère